you and in the last few moments four
people smugglers have been jailed for
their roles in the deaths of
39 migrants in a lorry container in
essex let's take you
straight over to the old bailey we can
speak to our crime correspondent martin
brunt bring us up to date martin
yes in the last few minutes the judge
has handed out
long sentences and i should say that's
not
unexpected um the judge has told
the seven men in the dock this was a
smuggling operation that was
sophisticated long-running
and profitable and had interfered with
the uk's attempts
to control uh immigration um the
the biggest sentence was reserved for a
romanian
george nika he's been given 27 years
in jail he was one of two
principals in this operation he had
admitted
smuggling people but had denied
manslaughter but he had been convicted
at the end of the trial
in december so he was given 27 years
it was his job to supply cars and
drivers to pick up
the migrants this end in essex once
they've been dropped off
from the lorry and deliver them to a
safe house
in london um the second highest sentence
20 years
has been given to ronan hughes an irish
hauler
he was one of the one of the other
principals
he'd been running legitimate operations
for many years but in between
legitimate cargos he was involved in
people smuggling
it was his job in this conspiracy said
the prosecution to supply
lorries and drivers he had admitted
all the charges he faced sometime last
year
so he's been given 20 years um
he had said during the trial that he had
usually smuggled
25 people in one container and of course
the trial had heard uh devastating
detail of how the 39 vietnamese
illegal immigrants had suffocated in a
trial
in a trailer the prosecution claiming
that because
a previous shipment had been discovered
the smugglers had loaded
the next trailer this doom trailer with
twice as many people
and that's why that why they died now
two lorry drivers
involved in this this operation have
been jailed now
eamonn harrison was given 18 years
he's from northern ireland he
claimed that he'd been smuggling stolen
lorry parts
but the judge has given him 18 years
morris robinson is the fourth
of the main members of this gang he's
another lorry driver from northern
ireland
it was his job to pick up the trailer
once it had arrived
in essex uh one day last october
by which time the migrants inside were
already dead
um he drove a few miles from the port at
per fleet
was ordered to open the doors and it was
maurice robinson
who discovered the dead bodies of the
migrants inside he's been given
13 years and four months
in in jail the judge has told
all of those who either con were
convicted or
had admitted manslaughter that they must
serve uh
two-thirds of those sentences um
there are three other members of the
gang who are currently being dealt with
by the judge and they'll have news of
their prison sentences shortly